>> Alright, so are any of these easy to answer right off the bat?
>> Well, one of them is really easy to answer
right off the bat, and that's minus 1 minus 1.
>> Good.
>> Because that's one of the points, so. [LAUGH]
>> Yeah. So, the joint strategy to get the minus
one minus one would be for both players to cooperate, right?
Again, they're just, you know, they're just willing to do that
just for the sake of showing they can make that value.
>> Right, and I think I know the answers for the other ones as well
>> Alright, hit me.
>> So here's how i'm going to, here's how I'm going to, going to talk
you through my reasoning so that if any point I'm wrong, you can
gently steer me away from embarrassing myself. Basically I was looking at these
points and I thought hm, they form a kind of a convex hull.
>> Aha!
>> And I thought well, surely that's just an accident of the numbers
and then I thought, oh wait, of course we're talking about averages here.
So that means that all sort of possibilities have to be inside the convex hull
of the outer points. So if I drew a line between those four points,
I would end up with all possible, achievable averages.
>> What, achievable averages, how? How would
you achieve things inside the convex hull?
>> I would appropriately average them. So in
particular, the first thing I'd notice that minus three,
zero, is outside that.
>> Mm.
>> So, it can't be, it can't be something you can achieve.
>> Right, there's no way to make this minus
three, zero, certainly not by choosing any of these
points, but also no combi, no convex combination, no
probabilistic combination of them, is going to do that either.
>> Right.
>> So, this one is just right out.
>> Right, so that leaves minus four minus four, and it
seems pretty. That's inside the convex hull, so there is some
combination of them that would work.
>> That's right. Any, any sense of what it would be?
>> 2 3rds, I think 2 3rds D,D 1 3rd
C,C. And I get that by noticing that D,D is minus
six, minus six, and C,C is minus one minus one, and
four minus four is two thirds of the way between there.
>> Boom. Cool. Alright, so you're good with that?
>> I'm good with that if you're good with that. It's your quiz.
>> Yeah. I'm excited.
>> Oh good.
>> So those, it's this, this, the minus one
minus one and the minus four minus four are,
as as you pointed out there is a more
general result here. Having to do with the convex hull.
>> Right.
>> Alright, so through the magic of computer graphics, I have a
slightly better depiction of this particular
region now. As you pointed out this,
this convex hull of the points is really important and what it
represents is the, we can call it the feasible region, these are average
payoffs of some joint strategy they, they may have to
collude to do this. And they may not be particularly happy
to do that. [LAUGH]. But the fact of the matter is,
they can achieve, by working together, payoffs anywhere inside this region.
>> Huh, so that's what my student Liam
always meant when he talked about feasible regions.
>> Maybe so, I mean it could be that he meant any number of
other things like places he's willing to live when he goes to get a job.
>> No, it was all game
theory stuff, I just never knew what he was
talking about, but now I do Michael, thanks to you.
>> Sure, hey I'm, I'm happy to help. So
this is a really useful kind of geometric way
of picturing something that would otherwise be a little
bit harder to see, I think in the matrix form.
>> Sure.